la première confrontation en france
entre des jeunes et des scientifiques
cela avait pour cadre arc et senans dans
le doubs un thème de réflexion important
l'avenir du monde et les hommes qui y
vivent
un organisateur le cnrs soucieux de
créer aviez un vrai dialogue pardon
enfin sur place il y avait dominique
dumas si les sciences peuvent paraître
obscur insolite
elles doivent être maintenant comprise
par la majorité c'est la démarche de
jeunes d'horizons les plus divers et de
80 scientifiques qui se sont enfin
expliqué arc et senans on a remis les
pendules à l'heure les thèmes abordés
religion éthique médicale société était
grave certes mais le dialogue en plus
facile malgré quelques nuances des
réticences ou des reproches domaine
scientifique
je dirais bien que j'ai pas trop proches
allaient se faire si ce n'est
actuellement il a du mal à trouver les
moyens d'intéresser les gens justement
est de les faire parler malgré cette
politique est évidente
nous sommes là pour que les problèmes
que pose la science soit des problèmes
qu'ils soient de plus en plus partager
et discuter dans le monde des citoyens
parce que je crois que ça concerne la
démocratie elle-même avec gaël et
mohamed benoit leblanc aux faussaires de
van gogh et sculpteur il est venu par
curiosité il ya un risque certain
discours et phrasés création d'un grand
pays ça fait penser surtout si vous
risquez de changer de métier et non pour
ces sculpteurs
examen d'entrée réussi pour les
scientifiques le courant est passé avec
les jeunes venus les rencontrer
l'expérience sera donc renouvelée a dit
hubert curial d'une mousse très
dorénavant l'intelligence et le dialogue
deviennent prioritaires